today on the matt wells show a school in
kentucky holds a man pageant quote
unquote where high school boys and
lingerie gave lap dances to their
teachers uh while a school in florida
brought elementary schoolers to a gay
bar for a field trip and that was all
this week so what is the issue with all
of this is it an infringement on
parental rights yeah
but that's not even half of the problem
we'll talk about that today also an
uncharacteristically impressive
performance from republicans as they
interrogate attorney general garland
during a senate hearing and a woman is
brutally assaulted on a train in new
york while dozens of people stand by and
watch this is becoming a theme plus a
professor at rutgers claims that black
and brown people lived in peaceful
harmony across the globe
until white people ruined it all and
anthony weiner's estranged wife says
that she was sexually assaulted by a u.s
senator the problem is that her sexual
assault story does not feature an actual
sexual assault we'll discuss all of that
and more today on the matt walsh show
a washington post article published late
last week tries its best to articulate
and defend the anti-position in the
parental rights debate authors jack
schneider and jennifer berkshire argue
that parents in fact do not have quote
the right to shape their kids school
curriculum and they chalk up the current
school board movement and the activism
by parents to nothing more than a
misguided quote frenzy
based on the they say false idea that
radicals are out to curtail the
established rights that americans have
over the educational sphere
well that is in fact exactly what is
happening but the washington post says
otherwise what they say is quote what's
actually radical here is the assertion
of parental powers that have never
previously existed
when do the interests of parents and
children diverge generally it occurs
when a parent's desire to inculcate a
particular world view denies the child
exposure to other ideas and values that
an independent young person might wish
to embrace or at least entertain
the
turnover all decisions to parents to
turn over all decisions to parents and
then would risk inhibiting the ability
of young people to think independently
as the political scientist robert reich
has argued minimal autonomy requires
especially for its civic importance that
a child be able to examine his or her
own political values and beliefs and
those of others with a critical eye if
we value that end the structure of
schooling cannot simply replicate in
every particularity the values and
beliefs of a child's home
unquote
well then whose values and beliefs
should they replicate
these kinds of defenses of the education
system never seem to answer that
question directly we're told that
parents by getting overly involved in
their kids education maybe maybe
inhibiting their children's ability to
think independently
but there is no environment on earth
perhaps outside of communist china or
north korea
more stifling to independent thought
than the school system
you know there is an orthodoxy in the
schools a certain accepted mode of
thought and those who fall outside of it
um face punishment from their teachers
and even more ruthless penalties from
their peers
and in fact the whole idea of
independent thought among children
is somewhat nonsensical
a child's thoughts are going to be
dependent
on something
or at least based in
something they're going to be basing
their values their priorities their
views of the world on some sort of
framework that's provided to them by an
outside authority
a child dropped off on a desert island
as a toddler and raised by seagulls
might become a truly independent thinker
in that his thoughts are formed
independent of any cultural context or
pre-formed value system but kids within
society will not be anywhere close to
entirely independent in their thoughts
or in any other sense children are
shaped they are formed and the question
is simply who can be best trusted to do
that
the left answers the school system
but it's too cow but they're too
cowardly and dishonest to actually
answer the school system i mean that is
their answer but they won't say it out
loud so instead they try another one of
their patented baits and switches where
they tell you to bring your children to
school so that they can become free
thinkers and as soon as you drop your
child off and head to work
they turn to your child and say okay
junior here are all the things you're
allowed to think and here's a list of
things you aren't allowed to think
yeah that's the free independent
thinking in the school system
that's why this is again
a question of who can best be trusted to
impart values
and on that end as you deliberate over
that question
consider this news from a school
district in kentucky this just happened
this week wdrb in kentucky has the story
listen
an event at hazard high school causing
outrage and now an investigation the
school is celebrating homecoming week
yesterday was costume day featuring a
man pageant multiple pictures were
posted and taken down from the school's
athletics page they appear to show
students giving lap dances to faculty
and staff some pictures show female
students dressed in hooters costumes
other pictures show students and staff
paddling each other one person featured
in the pictures is principal donald
happy mobilini who is also the mayor of
hazard some parents say they are
outraged others say they don't think any
lines were crossed everybody who has
been to hazard knows knows all of the
teachers and what happens during
homecoming week
wearing the mask of course
as expected
so male students dressed in bikinis and
lingerie
gave lap dances to teachers
and then teachers and students were
paddling each other
and this was all posted by the school
itself on its facebook page
the degenerate lunatics running these
schools are such degenerate lunatics
that it doesn't occur to them that
people might have a problem with high
school boys and lingerie giving lap
dances to their principal
that's how deeply they're invested in
the delusion of their own moral
authority
it doesn't cross their mind
that what they're doing is inappropriate
which is not an excuse by the way very
far from it my point simply is that
these people are helpless perverts
corrupted beyond all human recognition
another example just from this week a
school district in keller texas has
stocked its school libraries with a book
called genderqueer
which features cartoon images of oral
sex discussions of masturbation among
other among other topics both written
about and illustrated
meanwhile down in broward county florida
school board member sarah leonardi
proudly announces
that she chaperoned an elementary school
field trip to a gay bar
students from wilton manor
elementary school were taken to rosie's
bar and grill a quote lgbtq friendly bar
and grill decked out with rainbows
everywhere and featuring menu items like
the big dripper wrap the young ranch
hand the banana hammock
the naked sweaty lovin and ivana hooker
those are all menu items
at this gay bar and grill where the kids
were taken
this is apparently an annual field trip
and once again the school officials
responsible publicized it themselves
they either aren't expecting the
backlash or they couldn't care less if
they get it one of the intended
consequences of painting parents as
domestic terrorists is that school
officials will feel increasingly
justified when they run a foul of
parents
i mean if a bunch of domestic terrorists
are upset then you must be doing
something right
but there's another another point to be
made here and it's it's an important
point
that i think is is getting lost
the issue in education
is not just parental rights
in fact parental rights are a secondary
concern
because parental rights are not absolute
we all agree and understand that parents
can and sometimes should lose their
rights if you abuse your child if you
mistreat them you can lose your rights
as a parent
and we all agree in principle that that
can and should happen
so
what matters first and foremost then
is the basic liberty and human dignity
of the child himself
parental rights are indeed under attack
and we should defend them but we make a
mistake when we frame this entire issue
as nothing but a parental rights issue
so what's wrong with boys in lingerie
giving a lap dance to their teachers or
children being exposed to pornography in
the school library
or third graders being brought to a gay
bar on a field trip
is the problem simply that the parents
didn't approve
what if the parents did approve
i'm willing to bet that all of the
parents of the children at the gay bar
did indeed give their blessing in fact
in some of the pictures you see a bunch
of adults standing around
i'm guessing a lot of parents in that
crowd
some parents apparently were fine with
the lingerie lap dance
some are okay even with their kids being
exposed to pornography or worse
so is is that it then
is this just a matter of getting a
democratic consensus among the parents
and as long as they all agree to
sexually abuse the kids then it's fine
no because the principal concern here
again
is the freedom and dignity of the child
this is about the children's rights
first
as we've seen sadly there are plenty of
parents in our culture who will gladly
infringe on their own children's freedom
and dignity
but we defend parental rights not
because parents have the absolute
authority to do whatever they want to
their kids but because parents can be
most trusted to care for and guard and
protect their children
not absolutely trusted but most trusted
so our cultural default position should
be to entrust children to their parents
because that's the natural way of things
if a parent proves themselves unworthy
of that trust say by taking their kid to
a drag queen story hour then they should
have their parental rights revoked at
that point
but what we know for sure is that the
school system
cannot be trusted at all
at all to protect the dignity and
freedom of children
because that is again what this is
really about
those images you saw of the kids in
lingerie
that is an assault on the dignity and
and true freedom of children
and the school system is much more
likely to be a direct and intentional
threat to that dignity and freedom
which is why as for the school system
i kind of like the solution
inadvertently offered by the washington
post article i mentioned at the top the
piece ends with this here's the final
paragraph it says
in framing our public schools as
extremist organizations that undermine
the prerogatives of families
conservatives are bringing napalm to the
fight
they may rally the base and uh tilt a
few elections in their favor but as with
any scorched earth campaign the cost of
this conflict will be born long after
the fighting stops
parents may end up with a new set of
rights only to only to discover that
they have lost something even more
fundamental in the process
turned against their schools and their
democracy they may wake up from their
conspiratorial fantasies to find a pile
of rubble and a heap of ashes
a pile of rubble and a heap of ashes
sounds good to me
that's exactly what i want the school
system to become
metaphorically
it is a cursed and sickly and
dilapidated thing
so burn it to the ground and start
over now we check in with policy genius
you know uh shopping for life insurance
before policy genius was one of those
things that was difficult to do you
would put it off and that's not a good
idea to put it off because you put off
getting life insurance until it's until
it's officially too late but policy
genius has made it so much easier and
it's very simple to compare quotes from
over a top a dozen top insurers all in
one place why compare well because you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
the license experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance company
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of service has
earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google and um and eligible applicants
can get covered in as little as a week
thanks to an award-winning policy option
that swaps the standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call so
they make it easy to do
they make it affordable as well
and uh so there's no reason not to do it
you gotta head to paulista genius and in
minutes you can work out what kind of
life insurance you need and you get the
life insurance and then you have your
loved ones protected for the future head
to policygenius.com to get started right
now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
all right um had an uh enjoyable night
last night we went to as we continue uh
as i told you with my kids
every holiday they celebrate seven or
eight times and um so we continue the
week-long uh or two-week-long halloween
celebration we went to the boo at the
zoo here in nashville
big fan of the nashville zoo
and zoos in general
so of course i wanted to be a part of
this i mean i was a little upset when we
went the animals there was no animals to
see
um
but
you know they still they got candy and
all the kids were dressed in costumes
and uh for me
the headline and and um
the takeaway from me is that when we
were walking along
and we come across this other kid about
the about the same age as my as my
youngest son who's almost five years old
this other kid looks to be about five
and um this kid is dressed as a
gingerbread man
and then we saw probably three or four
other kids about the same age dressed as
gingerbread men
and my wife starts talking to the
parents of the one kid dressed as a
gingerbread man and that that the
parents say oh yeah you know he's
obsessed with the gingerbread man he
wants to read stories every night about
the gingerbread man and this was such a
relief for me because
our son is exactly the same way he's
obsessed with
with the gingerbread man and every
single day he wants to read stories
about it
and he was gonna go as a gingerbread man
for halloween but he changed his mind at
the last minute like kids always do he
wanted to be a werewolf instead okay
but it's one of those
i always thought it was kind of weird
like why
ginger this is a year-long obsession
with a gingerbread man why is this the
thing you're obsessed with
but um you have these reassuring moments
as parents
when there's this really weird thing
about your kid and then you meet another
parent they tell you about their kid oh
okay well this is so your kid's weird in
the same way so it's okay my kid's not
as much of a freak as i thought that's
that's reassuring to find out
um
okay so we'll start with
with this uh a.g garland was again
before a senate committee being
questioned about
um a variety of things
and there were a few really good moments
from republicans during this
and it's not often that i can really
give any props to elected republicans on
this show but when those opportunities
arise i will take advantage of them and
in this case some of the republicans
during this hearing were i mean
i would even say masterful in their
takedown
of uh of garland so we'll start with
this from senator holly who uh i think
speaks for many of us in his uh
treatment of of garland listen
parents who go to school board meetings
mr smith is a parent who went to a
school board meeting i'll leave it at
this general garland you have weaponized
the fbi and the department of justice
your u.s attorneys are now collecting
and cataloging all the ways that they
might prosecute parents like mr smith
because they want to be involved
in their children's education and they
want to have a say in their elected
officials it's wrong it is unprecedented
to my knowledge in the history of this
country and i call on you to resign
thank you mr chairman
uh yeah resign in disgrace that's
exactly what what garland should do
and i thought cruz's questioning
of garland was uh talking about why he
should resign
a lot of reasons
wep as holly points out weaponizing
department of justice against parents
um
for the department of justice to be to
be corrupt and weaponized that in and of
itself
is certainly not uh unprecedented
obama did the same damn thing
but to be weaponized in this way
against parents in general at school
board meetings yes that is unprecedented
um that's not the only reason why
garland should resign there's also some
real corruption and nepotism going on
and cruz's question of garland was was
tremendous on this end
um
garland would probably consider it an
act of terrorism given how thoroughly he
was dismantled and embarrassed by ted
cruz let's listen to a piece of that
a big part of this this letter is that
they're upset about parents not wanting
critical race theory talk
your son-in-law
makes a very substantial sum of money
from a company
involved in the teaching of critical
race theory
did you seek and receive a decision from
an ethics advisor at the department of
justice before
you carried out an action that would
have a predictable
financial benefit to your son-in-law
this memorandum is aimed at violence and
threats i just asked a question did you
see no predictable did you seek an
ethics opinion it has no did you seek an
ethics opinion judge you know how to ask
questions and answer them did you seek
an ethics opinion you asked me whether i
sought an ethics opinion about something
that would have a predictable effect on
something this has no predictable effect
in the way that you're talking about it
so if critical race theory is taught in
more schools does your son-in-law make
more money memo has nothing if critical
race theory is taught in more schools
does your son-in-law make more money yes
or no this memorandum has nothing to do
with critical race will you answer if
you thought it kind of curriculum will
you answer if you saw it i am answering
the best i can yes or no did you seek an
ethics opinion this memorandum has did
you seek an ethics opinion this
memorandum has nothing to do with
general are you refusing to answer if
you sought an ethics i'm telling you
that there's no possible so you're
saying no just answer it directly you
know how to answer a question directly
did you seek an ethics opinion i'm
telling you that if i thought there was
any reason to believe there was a
conflict of interest i would do that
he really looks like he's about to cry
uh i wish he would i wish he would just
i wish he would have
that was my only disappointment watching
that interrogation go on is that i was
hoping garland would break down in tears
he seemed like he was on the verge of it
and um
and you could understand why in a way
because these are people who
are never challenged
um by anyone
especially not publicly like this
in front of the entire country but
they're just they live in their bubbles
and they're never challenged
and if they encounter something like
this a real line of questioning they
don't know how to respond to it
i would almost prefer
if the tyrants running our country
if the tyrants in the ruling class like
garland i'd almost prefer it if they
were you know intimidating
and imposing figures
it would be it would be less a little
bit less embarrassing for the rest of us
in that case
because then you would see them and say
okay well yeah they're a tyrant what's
what's what you would expect a tyrant to
look like and but no these these frail
empty pathetic
little weaklings
on the verge of tears because you ask
them difficult questions those are the
tyrants and oppressors that we are um
who whose thumbs we are living under
you watch that you you almost feel sorry
for garland because he's so pathetic
and then you remember that he's a
colossal piece of garbage and you don't
feel so bad for him anymore speaking of
colossal pieces of garbage senator
spartagus um cory booker wasn't having
any of this whatsoever so he's he
swooped in to defend
um
garland and he's incensed that that
anyone would suggest that the doj's war
on parents is anything less than noble
and necessary and he tries to explain
why here
the october fourth memo reads in recent
months
there's been a disturbing spike in
harassment intimidation and threats of
violence against school administrators
board members teachers and staff who
participate in the vital work of running
our nation's public schools is that true
yes sir
i i mean it is true it is true i i have
a list of of
very disturbing incidents
in texas a parent physically assaulted a
teacher
august 18th 2021 in pennsylvania a
person posted threats in social media
which required
police to station outside of a school
district law enforcement investigating
the person i could keep going ohio a
school board member was threatening
letter that began with we are coming
from you domestic terrorism the united
states sir has it been more from
overseas
radical terrorists since 9 11 are more
from homegrown terrorists most of them
being right-wing extremists
which has been greater since 9 11.
i i want to be careful about that the
the threats that we face uh with respect
to terrorism and and none of those
descriptions have to do with terrorism
but the the threats that we face in the
united states come both from foreign
terrorists a church
in south carolina a synagogue in pennsyl
in pennsylvania a school
parkland a school
new town has there been threats and
violence against schools in the united
states of america there have been yeah
coming from what types of groups
they come from domestic groups from
domestic groups
parkland and newtown
what does that have to do with anything
whatsoever
cory booker
um
living up to the title that i gave him
of a colossal piece of garbage
is tying
at parents who get angry at school board
officials
to the the sandy hook massacre
and the parkland shooting
i shouldn't need to say no relationship
at all between those things
what are you suggesting with it that um
that these school shooters were upset at
their school boards
over policies they didn't approve of
now booker he wants to he's he's saying
oh no there have been um there's been a
lot of violence against school burmese
and then he starts listing them
and what does he list he said he lists
three things then he says i could go on
could you really
could you go on because i don't think he
could
i think that's basically all you had
he lists um
two uh examples of people
using threatening language allegedly
on facebook or in a letter
so no no physical violence there and the
one violent incident he talks about
the assault of a teacher
in case you're wondering what happened
there this was back in august
allegedly there was an argument between
a parent and a teacher
and during the argument the parent
pulled down the teacher's mask face mask
shouldn't do that okay you're making
physical contact with somebody else uh
you shouldn't do it
and but
that's that's your example like that's
why the department of justice the fbi
needs to get involved
because a parent reached out and did
this and pulled the mask down
that's all you got that's the best you
could do
oh i hope the teacher
recovered from that i wonder how long
they were in the hospital after that
better check on them maybe they're still
in a coma after having their mask pulled
down
um
and he takes that and ties it to
domestic terrorism what he's saying is
that a a
an angry parent
acting inappropriately and pulling down
a teacher's mask is akin to domestic
terrorism
um on the level with a school shooting
where 19 people are murdered
this is what we're getting from these
people
senator dick durbin um gave gave his
gave gave this a shot also trying trying
to to demonstrate to the public
why uh school boards really are under
threat and why the fbi needs to get
involved
and he says that he knows that the
threats are very real and that all of
this is very real because he saw it in a
search engine watch
those who think the insurrectionist mob
of january 6 was merely a group of
tourists visiting the capitol ignore the
pillaging
the deaths
and the serious injuries to over a
hundred law enforcement officials
and those who argue that school board
meetings across america are not more
dangerous and more violent than in the
past or ignoring reality
i went on and just typed in this morning
school board violence
on
one of the search engines
page after page is coming up
so this is uh right in line with with
with garland who at the last hearing if
you recall said that well how do i know
that that school boards are being
threatened because
they told me so in a letter
from the national school board
association they claimed it and also i
read it in the headlines and durbin is
saying oh i googled it
i googled it this morning and it came up
with a bunch of search result answers
so there you go
i mean that that at least he's being
honest about the the research that he
did and when most people say that
they've researched an issue these days
that's all they mean they mean that they
plug something into google and they saw
a bunch of hits come up and they said
well
there it is
even though you know 90 of the links are
just repeating the same story over and
over again
but dick durbin you know has been in the
senate for 150 years this maybe is the
first time that he's ever even used the
search engine so maybe we can excuse him
there
um but that's how that's how pathetic
listen if if they had something if they
had a real case here
they'd make it by now
if there were examples of
real um dangerous violence especially
multiple exams an epidemic of it
happening at school remix they tell us
about it
it's not like this is an ace up their
sleeve that they're saving for another
time
they don't have it
all right let's move on a rutgers
professor was um interviewed by
the race-baiting website the root and uh
she babbled on for several minutes
spewing blatant racism
but it's this part in particular coming
from a professor
that really caught my ear listen
i think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here you know
i've heard people sort of say it is
one i think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that white people don't
know right what they have done they know
they fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human which is to so you know like you
talk to white people and whenever you
really want to have a reckoning about it
they say stuff like you know it's just
human nature if y'all had all of this
power you would have done the same thing
right
and it's like no that's what white
humans did white human beings thought
there's a world here and we own it prior
to them black and brown people have been
sailing across oceans interacting with
each other for centuries without total
subjugation domination and colonialism
so we're going to kind of skip right
over the explicit racism
[Music]
only because what else is there to say
about it other than this is explicit
racism
and um etc and so forth
reverse the races white professor saying
this about black people
uh they would be fired within 30 seconds
and there would be marches and rallies
and the president would be talking about
it and um so
so we know all of that
which isn't to minimize it but
we know all that
or at least the audience of this show
knows it
um but then coming from a professor
her her vision of history
where she says that uh black and brown
people they weren't they weren't
subjugating each other what
okay go go pick up any um history
textbook or
you know
this is something you could even this
one you could google
look up a list of um empires throughout
the world throughout history
you're gonna see things like the ottoman
empire the aztec empire the mayan empire
the inca empire uh the persian empire
the egyptian empire the assyrian empire
et cetera et cetera et etc
um these were not empires built and run
by white westerners or europeans
or white americans okay
but they're empires and and how do
professor
what do you think an empire is
how do you think an empire is
established
you know the ottoman empire when they
were building their their empire and it
was expanding
were they showing up to other countries
and other regions and um kind of
knocking on people's door very politely
and say would you mind
would you mind if we conquered you
yeah we got this empire thing going and
we really want to grow it and so we
would love to conquer
um your you've got some land here we
would love to take it
would you mind
they said sure yeah go ahead and take it
oh great and they shake hands well
that's not how it worked um these if
it's an empire at any point in history
especially in ancient history
they were grown by conquering and
subjugating and killing and enslaving
all throughout the world
now
it's it's this is historical
misinformation and historical illiteracy
on multiple levels because she also says
that not only were they peaceful and not
subjugating each other which is a total
fantasy but that they were crossing
oceans
and interacting peacefully with uh the
people on the other side of the ocean
that's also not correct
now there were plenty of non-white
cultures who uh were
you know seafaring
like the you know especially the
polynesians for example
but
nobody was traveling whole oceans and
setting up lasting settlements
until western
uh
until europeans were doing it they were
the first to do it
to cross entire unknown oceans
go to an unknown part of the world and
set up a settlement
so she's also not correct about that
and and by the way
the non-white non-western empires that
were not
traveling across
oceans
the reason why they didn't travel across
the ocean it's not because they had some
sort of ethical qualm with it it's not
because they said oh yeah there could be
um
there there could be usable land on the
other side of this this this huge body
of water
and there could be resources and there
could be slaves that we could take but
we're not going to do that because you
know
we want to respect their autonomy and um
we want to and they're going to be
indigenous peoples and
on that land mass and we want to respect
them
no they didn't do it because they lacked
the knowledge or the interest or the
ability
perhaps they didn't see it as in their
interest to you know there was enough
that they could take and steal and
conquer around them they need to travel
across the ocean to do it
college professor folks college
professor
and some of you in the audience are
paying
six figures i mean you are paying top
dollar you're paying enormous sums
to send your kids to school
to listen to [ __ ] like that
think about that for a second
i didn't go to college
at all i dropped at a community college
after one semester that's that that's
what i did
and i should i could be teaching her a
history lesson
i am far more knowledgeable than she is
as a as a i don't know what what subject
she teaches but as a college professor i
am far more knowledgeable than her
give me that money you know what
if you're gonna spend a hundred thousand
dollars sending your kid give me a
hundred thousand dollars and i will
teach your kid
i'm not going to say i'm going to do it
it's not that i'll do a tremendous job
but i'll do a better job than um than
these college professors will
you know what i'll do i'll cut i'll cut
it in half don't i'll do it for 50 000.
give me 50 grand and i'll and i'll
condense it i'll teach them in a month
they'll be in and out how about that
um
let's see what else we got here
we got a lot of stuff
not sure if we can get through all this
um
let's check in with uh the fda this week
the fda advisory committee recommended
that we start giving coveted shots to um
kids aged 5 through 11.
i'm going to play a very short clip from
one member of the committee this is eric
rubin and you tell me if this instills
you with a great amount of confidence in
the vaccine listen
but we're never going to learn about how
facebook vaccine is unless we start
giving it yeah that's just the way it
goes
so this is the nancy pelosi we've got to
pass the bill to find out what's in it
thing
except in this case we got to approve
the vaccine and inject it into
children's bodies to find out what's in
it or to find out at least if it will
harm them
here's here's what else all i'll say
about this
um
as
a parent of kids who are in that age
range
they are not going to be getting the
vaccine and the reason they won't get it
is because i love my kids
and i'm not saying that if you get your
kids vaccinated with if i'm not saying
that if you give your kids the cova
vaccine
that you don't love them
um
that's another one of those things that
i would never say
i wouldn't say it on this show which
will be on youtube i wouldn't say it
all right um
what else do we got okay
now we check in
go from the fda to the nyc subway system
where the good people of new york
commute in a peaceful and orderly way
and here's um some video that was taken
of a in what starts as i suppose an
argument
between a man and a woman
um i will say a black man and a white
woman
and i tell you that because i do think
the races are are relevant here
um
and here's how that ends up let's start
watching this here
my train riding nbc
tell me to take your childhood tell me
the word
okay punches are right in the face
and i just want to
they replay this a few times but i want
to keep playing it so that you can see
the reaction from everybody on the
subway
or lack thereof
[Applause]
you see that one guy standing closest to
him the guy in the ball cap
and i don't know if he's with that woman
i sure hope that he's not i mean if he
is if he was with her i hope he's not
anymore
but his response is okay we could turn
this off now
so that guy his response
um
i think he does you know in fairness to
him he does speak up and says hey hey
man
whoa
this is a woman who was just brutally
assaulted right in front of him and he
says oh whoa whoa man
and nothing else
everybody else on the plane there's on
on the train rather there's there's that
train is packed people all around
including a lot of men alleged men
biological men at least
and um
they just stand there watching this many
don't even like they're looking down on
their phones and don't even look up
except for the person who's using their
phone to record all of this and not
intervening of course
you know
this this is definitely a theme and it
has been it was only what last week two
weeks ago we had the story of um a woman
being raped on a train
there was no video of that that was at
least released to the public although
the police it would seem did have video
because that was videoed as well
and um raped on a train and uh no no one
no one intervened there were people on
the train just sat and watched it didn't
do anything
so it certainly is becoming a theme
now i say the races were relevant there
because number one again
if we're going by one standard here
we know
that if the races were reversed
certainly everybody would be saying that
we can can you imagine
a large white man
punching a black woman in the face
and there's video of it
that video would be everywhere
it would be a national crisis
we would know
the assailant we would know everything
about him right now we would know his
name or where he lives his job which he
would not have anymore and rightful
rightfully so
we know that's the case
this happens and um that's not the
reaction at all
but there have this is not the only
video of this kind that we've seen
of white women being assaulted
and i believe the other thing that makes
especially the race of the victim
relevant is that this is becoming sort
of a meme or
it has been a meme online for a long
time now about you know kind of
dehumanizing white women we know about
the karen meme
and i've been complaining about that for
months now
and people laugh about it i said the
karen meme is a racial slur
and it's it's used as an excuse to to
kind of dehumanize white women
and
and
so as this meme gains
you know gains popularity we see more
and more of these assaults on white
women
i think there is a connection
where you know we're sort of being told
it's it's like acceptable
for a white woman to be treated this way
and what what did she say to uh
quote-unquote earn that um that assault
she said take a chill pill apparently is
what she said
but then you you run into the fact that
um
as other people have pointed out online
you know if you live in new york
this this is what you voted for
this kind of lawless environment
and i and i understand the argument that
some people make that um hey
if i were on the train and i saw that
happen
i wouldn't step in either because i know
that um because of the racial dynamics
there's a there's a very good chance
that you know
i'm going to end up being charged with a
with a hate crime i'm going to have the
mob coming after me
the video is taken out of context and it
ends up online and next thing you know
they're coming after me
and my life is
destroyed and i understand that argument
i mean i understand it intellectually
it's self-preservation that you don't
want to get involved
but there's nothing terribly unique
about that
i mean cowards are always concerned with
self-preservation
it's that's not unique to our culture
but it's still cowardice
you know cowardice it's it's
not doing the right thing
not wanting to put yourself in harm's
way
to do the right thing
to protect the innocent you know
because you're concerned with preserving
your own safety and your own well-being
that's the coward's way
and there's a certain intellectual
rationale to it that we can all
understand yeah you don't want to get
hurt
you take the potential hate crime aspect
out of it the other issue is if you step
in you might get your your ass kicked
i understand that you don't you don't
want to experience that because it hurts
but um
there are moments in life where you are
just simply called to do the right thing
and and put your own safety and your own
potential potentially your own life on
the line you're called to do that
and the thing is if you if you don't if
you don't step up in that moment like
the guy that's on that video now
immortalized the coward
who watched this happen and and um
didn't do anything about it
yeah he he preserved his physical safety
he's not gonna have the cops coming
after him for a hate crime or anything
like that but he's given up his dignity
you know you've sacrificed your dignity
as a man you've sacrificed your
masculinity like permanently and you're
never gonna get it back
you've given up your self-respect
because there's no way you could live
with yourself and at least look at
yourself in the mirror and and feel any
pride
after something like that
um
it's it's not worth it
so even if you're preserving your safety
you're not preserving your own dignity
and it's not worth giving up your
dignity as a man
to preserve your safety
all right one other thing to play a
little bit less serious uh
if you want to see something mesmerizing
buzzfeed posted this and uh they said
it's mesmerizing anyway they posted this
and said this is a this is mesmerizing
art this is a modern artist doing her uh
art i guess
let's let's see what this looks like
[Music]
okay
so she's covered in paint
and playing she's like playing twister
on a canvas
and that's uh
that's the art
essentially
look at that look at the final product
there
looks like random splotches
quite beautiful splotches
[Music]
yeah i'll tell you exactly what happened
here
[Music]
that uh there you know there was
this is
there was some man who was trying to
you know
trying to make himself appealing to this
woman
she told she showed the man her art and
the guy said oh yeah that's that's great
art that's beautiful you have a lot of
talent
hey you want to go out this friday night
by the way
and ever since that happened this is
what this is what's being
unleashed on the world
but i will say you know you know you
might as well put that i mean that's as
good as any other modern art you'll see
might as well put it in a museum
[Applause]
some billionaire will pay a hundred
million dollars for it
i'll tell you this is my okay we could
turn this off now
oh and as the video continues she's
wearing less uh fewer and fewer articles
of clothing
okay
my problem with modern art is that it's
ugly and stupid and doesn't mean
anything
it's also it's also
just kind of cowardly
in a way
there's a kind of intellectual cowardice
to modern art that you see especially
if you can get over the the
abject silliness of it
there's intellectual cowardice to it
because you're not saying anything i
mean art is supposed to say something
it's supposed to
portray something
there has to be some coherence to art in
order for it to be art
but when you when you actually
produce coherent art when you're when
you're saying something that can be
understood and interpreted
when you're trying to portray something
you know here's here's my painting of an
actual thing
when you do that then there's an
objective standard people can judge it
against
and they can say oh you tried to paint a
picture of a tree well you know that's
it's it's not a great tree
or or you're trying to say this or that
with your art well you didn't do a very
good job of conveying it and so they can
judge it there's an objective standard
they can judge it against
part of modern art the the goal of
modern art is to escape that
objective standard so that nobody can
judge it no one can say it's bad because
bad compared to what
they can't say oh you did a poor job of
conveying this or portraying this
because you're not trying to convey or
portray anything
which is of course in the end exactly
what makes it bad the worst kind of art
in fact
okay now let's read the comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
taimi shu says matt what did christ mean
by live by the sword die by the sword
does it have a broader implication for
self-defense war or justice
uh of course it has implication for all
those things but this is why when you're
reading the gospels when you're reading
anything in the bible
you can't you know you can't proof text
you can't
just quote mine or or or
you know you go you go kind of mining
for a certain verse or certain phrase
you take it out of context
just like people do when they're doing
just like dick durbin did when he was
researching on google
and then you think that it proves your
point you can't do that you have to
understand
you know everything in the bible within
its context and sometimes the and the
context is always pretty complex
and anything that you any quote you read
from jesus in the gospels
you have to understand those quotes
within the context of everything else
that he said
so live by the sword die by the sword is
a perfect example of if you take it
you take that verse those
you know six words six seven words take
them by
themselves outside of the context of
everything else in the gospels and
everything else in the bible hold a new
testament and then it would seem that
jesus is saying that you should never
use a weapon
at all
for any reason
um even to defend yourself
but then you you read it within the
context of everything else in the
scriptures and it becomes clear that
that's not the case at all
i mean to defend yourself
to do your duty to and defend your
family
certainly violence is acceptable there
jesus christ
used violence
on at least one occasion
clearing the the temple of the of the
money changers
that was not done peacefully
it says that he fashioned a whip in fact
it says i think it's significant that it
says that he fashioned a whip
not even that he grabbed one but he took
the time to actually make a whip
to then go and use it
on people
to drive them out and why because he was
defending
you know the the sacredness and dignity
of the temple
and it's okay to use violence in some
circumstances
for that
so you understand within context and
it's clear that um
you know jesus was not
anti-violence
as a general statement
um
austin says i once interacted with
someone who said that dogs are people
too
they never occurred to me until recently
that they were being 100 serious our
culture's inability to make distinctions
is horrifying
yeah this was something that for me also
it took a while to sink in oh no
people
this is actually a belief system that
that lots of people hold that dogs and
people are equal but we won't get into
that again i think i've probably said
more than i need to say on that subject
sweet mama g says i had to skip it in a
poly pocket as a kid and as i got older
a walkman with shuffle and bass boost
and thought that i was living high on
the hog a tank though honestly i might
get one for my sweet baby g's they
already have a roller coaster seven foot
climbing mountain a ninja warrior
obstacle a zipline why not a tank
before you say they're spoiled they are
my son is autistic and has epilepsy and
hospitalized a lot
i want to make his childhood as fun as
possible because tomorrow isn't promised
you have a roller coaster in your
backyard
can you where do you live i think i
think i want my my kids to be friends
with your kid that's
yes but you're right these are the kinds
of toys that we had as kids not roller
coasters the skip it see kids today you
don't understand this you don't
understand in the 90s what we had to
deal with
a skip it was like a plastic ball and
chain mechanism that you would jump over
and that was it
and we were ecstatic about it we loved
it we had something else called a bop it
and this was a weird box thing like a
plastic box and you would you would slap
the box and that's all you did you just
slap the box and
and
it was a fun game
we had a tamagotchi which is you know
kids have kids these days have the fancy
video games
we had the tamagotchi which is like the
primitive caveman hieroglyphic
of the video game world
and it was this pixeled blob on a
keychain that would eat its own feces
and then die of malnourishment
and we loved it
uh kids today i tell you what
let's see uh
joshua says hey matt i know i don't know
if this is the right place to ask you
questions but i was wondering how you
manage your time dedicated to work and
family how do you maintain a balance
betw between the two
as they're both very important
um
yeah well that's always the difficulty
is is
that work life balance and so on i will
say that as a man it really helps to and
i can't recommend this highly enough
it helps to have a wife who believes in
um in what you do
and supports what you do and i have that
so it's a lot easier to find that
balance
and uh
you know you would like to think that
that's sort of automatic in a marriage
but it's definitely not
and it makes a lot more difficult when
you don't have that
and finally dave says if matt were in
the position of being able to save the
life of a dog or a panda but not both
which one would he choose
are we talking about the burning
building scenario
well i would i would just i would never
run into a burning ban building for an
animal i'm sorry i just
i i wouldn't do that
that is
we talk about there are times for
courage there's times for
self-preservation
this is definitely a self-preservation
situation you know you got your own
family you got to get home too so
i'm sorry for the dog in the panda i
hope it's a quick death but i'm not
running in there not happening yeah i've
been telling you about this book that
just came out by 40 days for life what
to say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion and the reason i'm
telling you about it is that it is just
it is an invaluable tool for all
pro-lifers if you're a pro-lifer and you
want to be able to defend your position
and to defend the culture of life that
we're trying to build here in america
then um you need you need to have this
book in your library and since it's
released lots of people have gotten the
book it's been a number one amazon new
release and a number two amazon
bestseller the book is very easy to use
it tells you what to say what not to say
and the proven arguments that have
worked for everybody people on the fence
abortion supporters even planned
parenthood workers
um it's an invaluable and timely tool
you got to get it right now 40 days for
life by the way is a grassroots
organization pro-life organization and
uh one of the best ones in the world
they have
held peaceful vigils all across the the
world
and across america and they've helped
convert the hearts of 221 abortion
workers so you know these arguments work
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion how to change
minds and convert hearts in a brave new
world go to amazon or get it directly
from 40 days for life at 40asforlife.com
and also
you deserve nothing less than the facts
with your morning cup of coffee and
we're here to supply them on our newest
morning podcast morning wire not only
has it been topping the apple on spotify
charts since its release it's the only
daily podcast that values your time and
the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the facts we want
your help to keep the facts trending
towards number one so subscribe and
start listening now to morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and leave a five star review if
you like what you hear now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
huma abedin is uh one of those people
whose names you might know if you pay
attention to the news though it's not
entirely clear why why you know it or
why you should know it she's not a
public figure of any importance she's
not a politician
so you know she's got that going for at
least but she is a creature of
washington dc a former staffer to
hillary clinton estranged wife of creepy
sex pest anthony weiner and now she's
written a book and the book is called
both and a life in many words and it
promises based on the title to use a lot
of words to tell you about her life
whether or not the subject is really
worth all of those words in the first
place
and here's a tip for any memoirists of
the future
if the headline of your memoir
is that you use a lot of words in it
probably a good indication that you
shouldn't be writing a memoir in the
first place
though in huma's case she does have
another headline it's a headline that
has made lots of headlines over the past
day or two huma claims and she has all
of this in her book and you can read the
whole story for the low price of 24.99
she claims that she was sexually
assaulted by a united states senator 15
years ago
now she's not going to say the senator's
name or what state he represents or even
if he's still in congress
she says that uh she didn't even
remember the incident until the
kavanaugh hearings jogged her memory and
brought this buried trauma back to the
surface and that's how you know that
it's a very serious and truthful tale
she forgot about it for a decade she
waited to tell it publicly until she had
a book to sell
and she won't name the supposed sexual
assaulter who's still prowling the
streets perhaps the halls of congress
even nothing unique about that i suppose
but let's not dismiss huma's assault
claim based on its total lack of
credibility
let's also dismiss it because the
assault claim is not really an assault
claim
here's the daily beast describing this
traumatic ordeal
it says according to abedin's account
she and the senator met at a dinner
attended by several other lawmakers and
their aides in washington dc though not
clinton who was new york senator and
abedin's boss from 2001 until 2009.
following the meal abedine took a walk
with the senator who invited her into
his apartment for coffee
and she wrote told me to make myself
comfortable on the couch
then in an instant it all changed he
plopped down to my right put his left
arm around my shoulder and kissed me
pushing his tongue into my mouth and
pressing me back on the sofa she writes
abedine who said that she was so utterly
shocked pushed the senator away her
resistance surprised him and he
apologized saying he had misread the
situation and wanted to make up for it
without this ending badly she said
abedin wrote then i said something that
only the 20-something version of me
would have come up with i am so sorry
and walked out trying to appear as
nonchalant as possible a few days later
the two ran into another one another on
capitol hill and the senator asked that
they could still be friends
the end
now listening to this account of rape
you might be wondering when the rape
happens
it doesn't there was no rape no assault
if this event occurred at all there's
nothing much to report about it which is
why she didn't report it to the police
or anybody else until it was time to
hawk her memoir
what she describes here is something
that in more normal times
used to be called making a move
the man kissed her attempting to
initiate physical intimacy she rebuffed
him
he stopped immediately and apologized
this is what we used to call getting
rejected
it all adds up to nothing more than an
awkward story for the woman to tell
maybe even the man later in life when
the embarrassment is worn off
only in the age of me too has normal
heterosexual male behavior and normal if
uncomfortable interactions between males
and females become a human rights
violation
now
could there be a scenario where a man
kissing a woman might qualify as real
assault certainly if he had run up to
her on the street unannounced a stranger
planted his lips against her we would
categorize that as violent and a
criminal act
but this was not on the street
and it was not really unannounced
she went out to eat with him
came back to his apartment
for coffee quote unquote
human beings aren't automatons at least
we shouldn't be we speak to each other
not only using words but also through
signals
facial expressions body language
behavioral cues
a woman going up to a man's apartment
accepting his invitation for coffee
after a dinner date is a behavioral cue
the me too crusaders would have the man
ignore the behavioral cues and verbalize
everything like some kind of robot
excuse me human female you have accepted
an invitation to return to my apartment
does this mean that you are open to
romantic physical contact please answer
yes no or
undecided of course i'm way off base
here because even that wouldn't be good
enough according to the new rules
we're told that consent must be
affirmative verbal and continual
which means that just one confirmation
isn't enough the man would have to issue
this disclaimer repeatedly throughout
the night as things progress
the problem
is that humans don't operate this way
and despite the protestations of
feminists most women don't want men to
operate this way
so the standard here is that men are
being told to act in a way that no human
actually acts
and which is sure to alienate any real
woman in real life
and if they don't they'll be called a
rapist
meanwhile actual rapists exist in this
world and actual rape victims
but they are ever overshadowed by
attention-starved opportunists like huma
speaking of actual rapists they've got a
lot of them in the public school system
one of them raped a young girl in a
bathroom in loudoun county and that
story the one about real violent rape of
a child in a school
has already received less attention from
the corporate press than huma abedin
getting kissed by a guy while sitting on
his couch in his apartment
putting everything else aside
i think that's reason enough to say to
huma today that you are certainly
canceled
and that will do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the fda approves the fauchiochi for kids
aged 5 to 11 ted cruz destroys joe
biden's attorney general merrick garland
and twix candy bars reveal an
uncomfortable truth about radical
leftism and the occult check it out on
the michael knoll show